All right. We've decided that we are not going
to interrupt
Patriot Mail during the virus crisis and everything
else that's going on. We need a little levity
in our lives. Quick reminder about what hatred
at mail is.
Teachers can buy their own school supplies.
We'll throw in the Glock for free.
Hey, teary eyed man written by Patriots who?
Hey, David Pacman. Because America and big
cars. Freedom.
All right. And it is time for yet another
hatred e-mail that needs no introduction.
Take a listen.
Why not run with the hashtag? Hashtag bad
Jew. This is your calling card, Pacman. David
Pacman viewer finds out David Gay cancels
membership. Although it's obvious Pacman isn't
gay, he has a weird attraction to Tulsi, which
he reflects as saying her policys are bad.
Don't call Pacman gay, he's not gay. Don't
say that he's gay cause he's not seriously
for real. Not to mention most left wingers
are gay. You can look at Pacman and notice
it.
Yeah. Hash tag. Bad Jew. I actually can't
tell. Is this person more obsessed with me,
with gay people or with tool? I don't.
It seems like a very strange amalgam of those
three topics as the ones that this hatred
is focused on. And I'll remind you, you can
fight hatred, autism at this crucial time
by using the coupon code. Hey, tree at 40,
when you sign up at join packman dot com.
That's h h t r i o t for zero. You say 40
percent off of your membership and hatra its
cry because their hatred at male is impotent
to hurt the David Packman show. Yes. Very
good